hey guys as well no sure runners decided
to reel John's true identity through
brands vision in previous season bran
entered vision by communing with the
Viera tree in the haunted forest and
followed his father into the Tower of
joy whereupon he witnessed the reunion
between his father Ned and his dying
aunt Lyanna after emotional reunion
Leanna confided Ned with the protection
of her newborn son whose father is
Rhaegar Targaryen known as the Last
Dragon
so showrunners revealed John's true
identity John is not Ned's bastard but
rather a son of Lyanna stark and rhaegar
targaryen but it's yet to be seen what
his true name is the one that lianna
whispered into Ned's year as we all know
Ned Stark in order to fulfill his
promise that he gave to his dying sister
which was to protect her son Ned resultó
pass softly and his son as his own
bastard and also decided not to use his
nephews birth name which Liana whispered
to him a few moments before her death
but rather named him after his friend
and mentor Jon Arryn whom he loved like
a second father John's true name is most
probably Targaryen styled name which is
not only supported by a fact that his
father is Targaryen himself but it's
also supported by fact that Ned Stark
had to change his nephews real name into
John as his true name would have given
away his real parentage
as soon as season six finale ended many
fans were and actually still are
wondering what was the name that lianna
whispered to Ned
what is John's real name let's start
with a possibility that John's real name
is Viserys which might at first sound
out of the realm of possibilities but
there are a few hints that are going
favored to this theory it's a fact that
Prince Rhaegar Targaryen read the
prophecy in an arcane book about the
prince that was promised about the
prince who would save the world from the
return of the White Walkers
at first raggert thought that he was the
promised prince himself but later
thought it would be his children and his
apparently convinced that prophecy about
the prince actually referred to three
people acting together as the Targaryen
had first conquered and United Westeros
when led by three Dragon Riders Aegon
first and his two sister wives
Rhaenys and Visenya rehgar even in his
first two children after the original
three of the Targaryen conquests in
eration four
his daughter a niece and then his son
aegon the health of regars wife Elia
Martell suffered during her first two
pregnancies which resulted with
Rhaegar's decision not to have another
baby
Azealia would not survive an attempt to
have a third child and Rhaegar's
intention to help treat children
temporarily failed but eventually he got
his third child Italy in a start in
conclusion regarded named his first two
children after his ancestors but the
question remains did drag our name his
third child after the third head of the
Dragon which would be after Aegon's
second sister wife Visenya in my opinion
there are certainly high possibility
Visenya traditionally is a woman's name
but John might have been given the male
version of that name which would be be
serious there are a bunch of other names
that Rhaegar and Lyanna could have named
him such as the Harry suffrage occurs
first who was the fourth king of
Targaryen dynasty known as the wise king
who is also known for expanding the
Nights Watch honorable Ned Stark fulfill
his promise that he gave to his sister
Ned protected John Snow
but John's real parentage and John's
real name will certainly be revealed at
some point of the upcoming seasons in
the following videos I'll explain how
Jon Snow will most likely find out who
his parents are and what his real name
is let me know your opinion about all of
this in the comment section down below
I'm curious which name do you think
Rhaegar and Lyanna chose for their son I
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace
[Music]